よろしくお願いします
えーと 今日のテーマは何のために稼ぐのかというテーマで
一応まあ仕事やら採算やらね
そういうことについてまあ少々話していきたいと思います
で あの 聞こえないね 採算に対して
まあ一般的にはまあ欲が良くないとかね
まあいろいろなことを聞いておられると思いますから
まあこれもやっぱり明確に勉強した方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
で これ あの仏教というのは一概に極端的にあの喋ってるわけじゃなくて
あのちゃんと物事を厳密に具体的に論理的に分析した上で
真理を発見した上で語られてます
だから お釈迦様におっしゃられたものっていうのは
全く誰にでも いまだにそうではないと違いますということは
全く言うことは難しいんです
言うのはいいんで言えますけどね
ちゃんと根拠があって言うのは難しいんです
そういうことで あの順番であのあらゆるテーマに分けて分析して話します
まず この業ということで
あの業が命を支える 生きてる上で我々も生かしているエネルギーっていうのは
仏教では業と呼ぶんですね
これが ちょっとわかりにくい
ちょっとではなくても
かなりこの機能働きはまあ理解しにくいんですよ
行為と結果という風な話なんですけど
まあそちらにもまあ結果はいろいろあるんだから
ただ 窓ガラスに石を投げたら窓ガラスは割れるとかね
そういう風な行為と結果っていうのはすごい明白で
分析も説明もできます
しかし 必ずしも行為がその瞬間で結果出すということでもありません
例えば電気力を 電力を作ろうとダムを作って
そこで水を蓄えておく
だから ダムに水が蓄えたら
すぐ即座に電気が生まれてくるっていうことじゃないんです
やっぱりあのタービンに水を放出した時に限って電力が現れてきます
そこまではまあ一応原因は作ってます
水を溜まって浮いたという
でも結果は後なんですね
即座ではないです だからこのエネルギーっていうのは
なんかポテンシャルとしてあるということをね
あのダムに行ってみたら
何のエネルギーも見えませんよ
まあボートで遊ぶこともできるし
ほとんどもう波も立たない
ただもう溜まった水だから
川の方が激しいんですけどね
ダム作ったらそこら辺はただ湖になるだけでね
何のこともないんですよ
でもそちらにはなんかエネルギーは蓄えてますよ
だから水をそこで放出したら
かなり力で巨大なタービンを回して
すごいエネルギーを電気エネルギーを出してくれるんですよ
だから このポテンシャルとして
我々の体の中で 心の中でえらいエネルギー溜まってるんだけど
それ分かるわけないんですよ
ポテンシャルとして溜まってるんだから
ないと等しいように感じちゃうんですよ
でも結果が出そうとすると
なんとなく感じるんです
まあ人々でも何かいろんなことをやってる
やってる時 何かやる行う前になんとなくそうせざるを得ないような衝動がなんか絡んでから回って回ってるんですよ
悪いことであろうが いいことであろうが
まあなんかそれは行う前になんとなくこのエネルギーが出てきて
まあ回転する その時だけ感じますけど
もう遅いんですよ もう瞬時に結果出すんだからね
そういうことで このそれが仏教ではカンマと言うんですね
で カンマッサカーマナワサッターカッマダーヤーダーカッマヨーニカッマバンドーカッマパティサラナーえーと
カンマサッティビバゲティヤリダンヒーナッパニーティターヤっていうのは
このあるスバッというある人が
おそらく若者だと思いますけど
お釈迦様にもこの世の中にも差別
区別とは一体何なのかと
人々は長寿の人がいて
短命な人がいる 美しい人がいて
醜い人がいる 病弱な人がいて
すごい健康な人がいると
それで上の高貴なカーストで生まれる人がいて
すごい低いカーストに生まれて苦労している人々もいるし
豊かな人がいて ものすごい貧乏な人もいるんだと
何がこれ？バラモン人だったらそういうふうに神様が作ったんだぞと信仰すればいいのに
こいつはそう思ってなかったみたいで
何かお釈迦様に聞くんですね
お釈迦様が言うのは これはカンマだよと
業だよと で 業の場合は
だからお釈迦様はマナワっていうのは若者よということで
で 若者よ カッマッサカー
カッマッサカー 自分のものと言えるのは
自分のものっていうのは自分から決して離れないもの
一体になっているもの
それが業であると まあ肉体のことだけ考えてみると
目やら耳やらね これは自分のもので
こちらに忘れて置き忘れるわけはありませんね
カバンとか他のものだったら置き忘れちゃうんですよ
これはそれほど自分のものじゃないんです
肉体の場合は 目やら耳やら鼻やらね
一度でも置き忘れたことはないでしょうね
どこへ行って持っていくんですよ
しかし 肉体は本当は自分のものじゃないんですよ
例えば一部が故障しちゃうと
なんのことなくそこはもう切って捨てちゃうんでしょうに
自分のものだったらそれはできないはずなんです
体のいろいろところがね
悪くなると それは摘出するんですよ
し それ全部できなくなるんですよ
一部切ってしまえば その分自分の一部がなくなるんだからね
だから足一本なくなっても
両足もなくなっても 両手なくなっても
別に自分は自分なんですね
何かなくなったわけじゃなくて
ただ物質物体が一部なくなっただけで
だからそのたとえ それほどいいたとえじゃないんだけど
一応我々に分かりやすく言えば
肉体だけ考えちゃうと
目やら耳やら鼻やらね
そういうものは自分のもので
忘れることはありません
別に負担ではありません
どこへ行ってもっていくんです
業っていうエネルギーは
こそが自分のものなんですよ
それは肉体じゃなくて心の中にあるんですね
それは自分のものというのは業であると
我々は相続するのは業であると
いわゆる相続っていうのは
もうもう 自分自身なんですけど
自分がどこへ生まれ変わっても
犬になろうか 猫になろうか
鳥になろうが 死んでからね
幽霊になろうが関係ないんですよ
業は相続するんですね
業というエネルギーは
離れません どうしても
で それから人の生まれ
生まれっていうのは面白いことで
このパーリ語ではようにと言うんですね
で ようにっていうのは女性の体から生まれるんだから
そういうところを表す単語なんですけど
まあ私たち知ってる生命の中で
生命がどこから生まれたかの生まれたのかということによって
何者かがわかるでしょうね
雌犬の体から生まれたら犬であって
猫の体から生まれたら猫であって変わりませんね
別なものが生まれるわけじゃないんですね
そういうことで 私たちは何ものとして生まれているんでしょうかということは
業が決めるんです いわゆる業が生むんですよ
生命を 業って面白いことで
だからたまたまある一定の時間で我々は人間にいるだけ
人間として我々を生んだのは業なんです
それで親族 自分のもので言えばね
親族っていうのは養う頼りになるとかね
いろいろ親族の中で我々楽しく生きてますからね
親族として何があったら助けて助けてくれるものとかね
言えばそれも自分の心にある業であって
あの 自分のよりどころでもあります
人に頼んでも 他人に頼んでもどうにもなりませんよ
例えば病気になったら
あのお母さん 私の病気早く治してちょうだいって言っても
お母さんにはどうすることもできません
その人の業の力で病気が治るんですよ
病気が治らないで死んでしまったら
それもその人の業の力なんですね
だから このよりどころにするのは業なんですよ
で 業が生命を区別する
生命の区別は業によって成り立つものなんですね
だから二人とも同じ人間はいません
生命もそうなんですよ
1匹1匹違うんですよ
同一っていうのはありえないんです
すべての生命は互いに違うんです
その区別も業の働きなんです
分かりやすく言えば 他宗教で神という概念ですね
仏教では業と言っているのは
違うところは 業っていうのは自分が行うことなんだ
自分がやっていることなんですよ
人が人殺ししても 私は刑務所に行くわけないでしょうに
だからこの神と言えば他人ですよ
全くも 神の働き 全部こちらにまとめているんです
神の仕事は まとめているんだけど
神という他人が 第三者が人を上下に区別すると
優れた人と卑しい人にするんだそうというと
なんか道徳的に問題あるんでしょうに
なんで一人に人が障害者で
人の人が健常者で作るんでしょうかと
これちょっとおかしいし
道徳的には成り立たないんですよ
だから どう見ても仏教はそういう第三者によってすべて起きているのという無責任
それ無責任感ですね 私には関係ないんだと
私には責任がありませんと
すべて第三者たる力によって起きているものであるというのはね
で それが理屈通らないんですね
その代わりお釈迦様は
では何だと これ なんで人間でありながら区別ある
動物でありながら区別がある
幸福な人も不幸な人もいる
その区別はどのように現れるものかというと
あるエネルギーを発見したんですね
心という心の中にある業という働きがね
それは業ということなんですね
それで神と違うところ
よく覚えてほしいのは
業が私自身がやることだから
人に文句言っても意味がないんです
だからポテンシャルになったら訳も分からない
例えばすごい過去で悪いことをしたら
それがポテンシャルになっている
だからもう感じないんですよ
過去ですごいいいことをしたならば
それも今の心にポテンシャルとしてなっている
ポテンシャルというのは機能しないんですよ
百メートル上に石一個を持って行っても
別になんにも重さも何もない
何の変哲もないんですよ
しかしそれを落とすとかなり力になるんです
怪我する可能性もあります
百メートルから落ちちゃうと
もう当然怪我しますよ
体に当たったら大変ですよ
でも百メートル上にいたら何のこともない
もう だからポテンシャルとしては全然わからない
それが何て言いますか
エネルギーは このリリースというか
何でしたっけ え？放出するときで問題なんです
だから私個人がいろんな行為をする
すると その行為が全部もうポテンシャルになってなっていく
もう何のこともない もう忘れちゃいます
感じない でも場があったら放出する
それは避けられません
そういうことで 人間っていうのは本当にわかってるんだったらね
自分が事故を起こしたならば
それは自分の過去の行いだろうとわかったら
すごく別に納得いけるでしょ
あれ アメリカで船で若者がね
高校生たちがね 盗難事故を起こして死んじゃうとかって
私はそれは業ですよと言ったところで怒られるんですね
それは業は業ですよ だからその子供たちは過去生で何かした業の結果で短命になったんですよ
それに腹が立ったって
もうそれ自体が邪見であって
自分を戒めることはできなくなるし
だからこんなのは危ないんだから
やばいんだからね ずっともう
何て言いますか 身を控えて行動しなくちゃいけないということになるのに
わからないんですよ そこで業の仕事内容
いくらか言ったんですけど
また説明します 生 生まれを決めるんです
人間か畜生か神霊か神か誰かになるということは業がするんです
だから業が自分で作るんだから
自分が人間に生まれ変わりたければ
それなりのエネルギーを作らなくちゃいかない
神になりたければ それなりのエネルギーは自分が作らなくちゃいけないんです
一旦作っておけば 自動的にそのその結果は出てくるんです
それから その生命の上下関係
同じ人間に生まれてもまるっきり互い違いですよ
立派な人もいて 立派でない人もいて
そういうのは業がやっちゃうんですね
それから性別 それから寿命
これ本当に面白いことで
生命の寿命というのは決まることできないんですよ
この生物学的にいろいろ言ってはいますけど
それはもう一応あの何人かチェックして
もうもう割ってみて ジェネラルというか
何て言いますか 普遍的にまあこれぐらいだろうと言うんであって
人間百年ぐらいだろうと
でも必ずしもちょうど百年で死ぬということはないでしょうに
ちょうど百年経って零秒になったところで死んじゃったということはないんですよ
だから まあ科学的に生命の寿命が言えるならば
そういうふうに言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
それが言えないんですよ
時々すごい長生きする猫たちとかいるでしょうね
特に人間に飼われると
まあそれなりに  丁寧に飼っておくと寿命は長くなるんですよ
なぜならば 野生でいるといろんな悪いことをしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで丁寧に飼ってもらっちゃうと
何も悪いことをしないで
ただご飯を食って寝るだけの人生になるんですね
そういうことで 自分の持ってもらった寿命がね
結構機能する それで野生でいると
もう喧嘩しなくちゃいけないわ
狩りをしなくちゃいかないわ
そういう それは悪行為なんです
それで寿命はもう早く終わってしまうという
だからこの寿命っていうのは業が決めるんですよ
ちゃんと業が決めた寿命で
ちゃんと零秒になったところで死ぬんですよ
これは一秒も延びないんですよ
だから我々は今何時何分何秒に死ぬかということを
我々の心にあるポテンシャルは知ってます
知ってるっておかしいんだけど
そちらでは決まってます
その瞬間で死にますよ
これはもう絶対避けられません
もう命の法則だから 電気が消えたらもう光がなくなるっていうことだから
それから死の時期とその方法も業の仕事なんです
どんな風に死ぬか どんなところで死ぬか
一応業はそういうところを管理するんです
生きている時の管理 それから生きている間の管理も業がやってますよ
例えば頭良い子で生まれても
業で 業から見れば立派な大学出て
知事になって そういう生き方は決まってない場合は
試験受ける時はなんとかやっちゃって
もう拡大しますよ いくら頑張ってもできないんですよ
頭が悪いってわけじゃないんです
すごい微妙なんです だからこの障害あるかないかとかね
それから美しいかないかとかね
で 健康でいるかないかとか
それから我々の肉体の体力まで
業の仕事内容なんです
それだけじゃないんです
この生きるために必要なこの需要品をね
供給するのも業なんですよ
どんな服着るのか どんなご飯食べるのか
どんな家に住むのかとかね
どんな環境にいるのかどうか
どれぐらい人々と付き合うのかと
業によって決まっています
性格の構成 我々の性格も基本的には生まれ
そのある一つ一個の生まれ作ると
その生まれではどんな性格でいるべきかということも
業で決まってしまうんですよ
性格の基本的なプログラムと才能
能力なども業で一応作るんです
で 難しいが 努力によって性格が変えられる
難しいんですよ もう基本的にできてるんだからね
それ理性と理解があるならば
性格を変えることは簡単ですが
そうでない場合は一時的なものでしょうと
いうのは この仏教はすごく知恵と理性と知識っていうのをすごく褒め称えています
なぜかというと この理解能力あれば
理性があれば かなり物事は自由自在に管理できるんですよ
あんな手に負えない業さえも生きることはできるんです
必要な理性 知識 知恵 物事を正しく判断できる能力
それだったら全くつかみどころない業っていうのは実感もない
なのに変えることはできます
それってまた不思議なことじゃないんですよ
自然法則さえも我々人間に好きなように変えるっていうことは
人間の知識でやってるでしょうに
科学っていうのはそういうものでしょ
科学発展というものは
人間の知識で変えるはずもないものは変えてしまうんです
しかし 法則乗り越えられません
人間には空は空を飛べないはずなんです
どう踏ん張っても しかし
知識のある人々は人間空を飛べるようにするんです
それで私たち今飛行機の空を飛んでいるんだからといって
法則 宇宙の法則を変えたわけじゃないんです
引力の法則から何一つも変えてないんですよ
そのまま しかし 頭を使っているんです
その法則の中 同じく業の法則も変えることはできません
できませんが 理性あれば見事に操ることはできます
だから この性格なんか変えるっていうことは皆さんは知っていると思いますけど
そう簡単じゃないんですよ
もし理性があって理解能力があるんだったら
もう変えられます で そうでない場合は
あまりにも強引にしつこく言われると大人しくしようと頑張るんですよ
でもその言う人が亡くなっちゃうとまた元に戻っちゃうんです
あるいはあまりも自分にものすごい激しく
これからこういうことをやりませんよとはっきり決めて
すごいきつい気持ちでいると
性格は微妙に変わるんだけど
あのエネルギーが弱くなるとまたドーンと元に戻るんですよ
だから理性があったら
例えばこの 何て言います
ダイエットするそうと
ただ単に欲でやめそうと決めても
あのエネルギーがある時はダイエットできるんだけど
エネルギーが消えてしまったところでまた元に戻ってしまうんですよ
そうではなくて よく理解しておけば
食べ過ぎは体にも悪いし
あの もう情けないし 性格的にも良くないし
まあそれよりはまあ適量適量を食べているのはまあ正しいではないかと
こういうこういう食べ物はもう美味しく見えるんだけど
本当は内容は体に良くないんだそうと
よくわかるとすっごく簡単ですよ
そういうことで 理性っていうのは大事
まあ必要になるんです
まああのコンピューターのことをご存知の方々にとってはいい例えがあるんですよ
あの業っていうのはなんか WINDOWS XP みたいなもんで
あの基本的な OS なんで
それがないとパソコンは動かないんですよ
ただの代物で もうゴミのひとくくりなんですよ
しかし OS 入れちゃうと
まあこれから仕事できる状態になる
できる状態だけ しかし何をするのかっていうことは
入れるプログラムによります
だから OS もいろいろでしょうに
今はほとんど統一されちゃって
もうほとんど 2つぐらいになってますけど
まあいくつかありますね UNIX
やらなんとか何とかとかいろいろ
例えば UNIX で OS でコンピューター使う場合は
決して WINDOWS XPとは違いますね
やっぱり Unix を使う人々は
まあ例えば Linux というもの
プログラムありますね
そういうのを使う人々は
何かそちらの長所を見てね
例えばウイルス入りにくいやら攻撃しにくいとかね
そういうところを考えて
あるいは安いとかね あのオープンコードですから
好きに自分の好きなようにコンピューター変えられますとかね
いうことで使ったりするんだけど
使い方は違うんですよ
そのような感じですよ
業っていうのは 本当は気にしなくてもいい
我々は Word 作ったり使ったりする
これが何とかプログラムでしたっけ？何でしたっけ？ PowerPoint 使ったりする
私たちは PowerPoint どうやって動かすのかしか全然知らない
しかし  PowerPoint は Windows というプログラムなければ全く機能しない
そこで Windows でまるっきり気づくことなく PowerPoint を使っています
だから 私たちもいろいろ勉強したり
いろんな能力を身につけたりして
それはちゃんと知ってますよ
音楽の勉強で苦労したんだから
音楽できるぞと 音楽で食べていられるぞとか自慢はするんだけど
その音楽能力っていうのは
業という OS の上に成り立ってます
だから 業がその人を豊かにしてやるぞというプログラムがあるならば
音楽によって豊かになれる
苦労させるぞという OS だったら
音楽やろうがエンジニアになってやろうが関係なく苦労することになるんです
でも その OS には気づかないんです
それから良しからしから業は絶大で
ものすごいものなんですよ
幸福は業の働き 自分の人生に対していろいろと不満はあるかもしれませんが
業が自分なのです 私たちはどんな人間でもいっぱい不満を持ってますよ
もうちょっと顔が小さく小さい方がいいんじゃないかとかね
あと 3cm 背が伸びた方が良かったんじゃないかとかね
いろいろありますよ で
30代でも歯がもう壊れてしまう人々もいるしね
まあせいぜい 60年まででももった方がいい
あった方がいいんじゃないかとかね
いろいろ不満はあるんだけど
しょうがないんです 業が自分なんです
ただ まあ自覚ないだけ
自覚があったらすっごく落ち着くんです
失敗はしたくない 嫌な性格を変えたいと思う気持ちはあるが
理性 知恵と努力がなければ無駄に等しい
人間 いろんな希望があるんですよ
失敗なんかしたくないとかね
成功してやるぞとかそんなことを欲張って希望期待しても全然うまくいかない
だから仏教は欲望 希望と願望は危ないんだから捨てろと
ただ苦しいだけだよと
欲望があってもあってもそううまくいくわけじゃないんです
もしうまく行って欲しければ
たとえ貧困の家系で生まれても
貧困は嫌だと思ったならば
理性と努力と知恵というのはインスピレーションのようなものなんですね
そういうものを使うと
あの業が変わるんですよ
でないと変わらない だから欲望希望じゃなくて
人間理性働かすんですよ
そうすると 人生は自分の好きなように変えることができます
欲 怒り 高慢 見栄などの感情で夢を見て期待希望するが
結果は業が決める 人間は感情でね
見栄やら嫉妬やら高慢やら
いろんな感情でああなりたい
こうなりたい あしたい
こうしたいと思うんだけど
一つも希望通りにはいかない
業という OS が決まっている通りに行くんです
だから感情 欲望 希望 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみというのは
人間にとっては邪魔であって
全然助けにはなりません
それで問題は 今日は稼ぎの問題だからね
業があるのになぜ仕事をするということ
業っていうのはそんなに偉くて
もう寿命まで死ぬ瞬間と死ぬ方法まで業が決めるんだったらね
何を食べるかっていうことも業が決めるんだから
どんな服を着るのか どんな家に住むのか
全て業ですよ 業が決めるんです
だったら仕事する必要ないでしょうに
考えれば ないんだけど
それも業が決まってるんです
仕事をしろと 働いて必需品を得る生まれ
業が全てを揃ってくれる生まれもあるのです
いろんな生まれがあるんですよ
働いて自分で働いて必需品を揃えなさいというプログラムで
その場合は働く能力は与えてくれる
働かなくてもいい 全てオートで自動的に揃えてあげるぞという生まれもあります
その場合は働かなくても
例えば神々っていうのはそういう存在なんですね
仏教でいう神々っていうのは
仕事はしない ご飯も作りません
服も買ったりしない 天国ではデパートはありません
ただ生まれた瞬間で 完全な体で着るものやアクセサリーは全部ついてるんです
体に その神が何を食べて食べるのかっていうこともそれで決まってて
その瞬間に自分にそれあるんです
その場合は仕事をしなくていいんです
それから次の悪業の場合は
ほとんど必需品を与えないで命だけ維持する生まれもあります
例えば業は悪業だったら
業っていうのは言い忘れたんですけど
良い行為も悪い行為もまとめて業というんですよ
だから人は幸福になると
それは業 不幸になるとそれも業
ですから善業 悪業と言わなくちゃいけないんです
それで悪業を行ったら
それもエネルギーにポテンシャルになる
それで悪業によってどうなるのかというと
どこかに生まれ変わる
生まれ変わったら この業がその人の寿命はずっと維持してやるんです
死なせません しかし 必需品
必需品を与えてくれない
頑張っても頑張ってもないんです
必需品がないと死にかけているんですよ
ものすごい苦しいんです
死にかけてはいるんだけど
死なないんです 死なすかないかっていうのは
業が決めるんだから で
あの この地獄とかね 餓鬼道とか
は そういう生命なんですね
ものすごい苦しいんですけど
死なないんです だから必要なものがないということが苦しみなんですよ
食べたくて食べたくて
お腹が空いて ものすごい衝動があるんですよ
食べたいという でも何一つも食べるものは目に入らない
並の苦しみじゃないんですよ
そういう風に五感にすごい激しい苦しみが与えるんで
生まれるんで与えるんじゃなくて
業はそんな悪いことしない
業がただ悪業 だからもう悪いところにもう幸せを作っちゃうんです
そうすると寿命も決まってくるんです
それだけ 物は得る もらうエネルギーはないんです
もともとないんだからしょうがないんです
だから誰にも文句を言うことはできない
ただ苦しいだけの生き方になるんです
業により肉体をこれで肉体を持つ生命になると
その体は物質なので 物質の法則にも管理されます
これは我々とこの動物の世界の問題なんですよ
肉体を持ってるんですね
肉体っていうのは物質ですよ
外から最初の肉体の微妙なところは業作るんです
今も業によって肉体が構成されてますよ
では ほんの一部で 外の世界からの物質を入れて作らなくちゃいけないんです
そうなると この外から入れなくちゃいけない物質を入れるために仕事をしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで仕事をできる能力は業はつけてくれるんです
だから犬も猫も仕事をしていますよ
ライオンも仕事をしています
鳥たちも動物もみんな仕事をしています
肉体を持ってるんだから
仕事をして この肉体にかける部分はスーッと入れて入れて入れても一回入れてはそれで済むわけじゃないんです
全て無常だから 変化するんだから
入れても入れても入れても
またまた入れて入れていかなくちゃいけないんです
業だけではダメで働く羽目になるんです
肉体を持っちゃうと そういうわけで
仕事をしなくちゃいけないということになるんです
随分単純だと思いますけど
話は そういうわけで 逆に仕事をしないのは悪行ですよ
体を持つなら仕事をするべきという法則です
体を持ってるんだったら仕事しなくちゃいけないんです
わがままで怠けて仕事をしないと勝手に決めても
それは悪行になって苦しみを作り出すんです
人間に勝手に私は仕事をしませんよとそう決めることはできません
動物も同じ 私は狩りをしませんよと決めたら
誰かが狩りをして獲物を持ってくるわけじゃないんです
例えばちっちゃい小さい時
ヒナとかね 生まれたら
それでヒナの業があるんですよ
親鳥から餌をもらうという
親鳥は全然物事考えてなんともないんでしょうね
考えるってことは人間やっている仕事だから
でも随分大事に育てるでしょ
敵から守ってあげて あれが業なんですよ
それでその時期消えちゃうと親鳥は追い出すんです
出して忘れちゃいます
自分の子供っていうことさえ
巣立ちしてもうすぐ忘れるんです
だから我々飼ってるペットにも何か仕事をさせるとペットの方が幸せになるんですよ
仕事してるんだから ただ餌あげただけではね
あまり良くないんです
だからいろいろ芸を教えたり
いろんなことをしたりすると
頭の悪い犬とか勉強も理解しないんですけど
でもできるようになるとお互い楽しいんですよ
輪廻転生する限り 仕事は煩わしいと言っている場合ではありません
あれは輪廻転生しているんだから
肉体持ったり あっちこち転生するんだからね
仕事はなんか煩わしいとかね
今皆様なさってる仕事
すごく煩わしくてストレス溜まるんだったらね
もう期待してください
それは無限大に続くんです
生まれたなら仕事は義務であって責任です
それから稼ぎと仕事って同じものですか？と
同じではありません 微妙に違います
生まれた恵まれた環境なら
稼ぎは人生の中期だけやるものです
例えば 我々は恵まれた環境で生まれたならば
人生の中期でまあ 20歳ぐらいからとか
仕事をすればいい 稼ぎすればいいんです
貧しい環境なら子供老人も稼ぐんですよ
もう失うものはないんですよ
だから ちっちゃな子供でも学校に行くんじゃなくて
ちょっと歩けて なんとか手足
もうちょっと力がついてくると
もう何かしで仕事するんですよ
年取っても もうもう私は体弱いとかね
言っていられる場合じゃないんですよ
何か仕事しなくちゃいけないんですね
それ その仕事とは稼ぎですね
だから稼ぎの場合はそういういろいろ差があるんですよ
仕事は一生やるんです
生まれてから死ぬまでやるんです
赤ちゃんも仕事はしますよ
稼ぎはしません 仕事は生きている上で
その時その時 その その時期必ず行わなくてはならない行為です
仕事を言えば 例えば年
年は四歳ぐらいになったら
もう学問にせなくいけないんですよ
人間なら そういうことで
人間にはその時その時
どうしても避けられない
必ずしもやらなくちゃいけないということをする
それが 文字通りの だから仕事というのはworkという風に訳すれば
稼ぎというのはearnなんですね Work
とearnというのは二つなんです
区別した方がいいんですよ
仕事は一生やる 稼ぎは人生の中で一部の時間だけでやるんです
それから稼ぎの世界 人には衣食住薬
これ四具と言うんですね
必要ですよ 人間は余計に快楽も欲しがるんですね
あの四つだけで十分なんですけど
人間はまた快楽も欲しがるんです
それらを働いて稼がなくてはならないんです
外から必要なものだからね
これ なんでよ この快楽
余計と言ったんでしょうかというと
この四具ぐらいだったらいとも簡単に手に入るでしょ
四具ならベースにも一日稼いでいたら一週間ぐらいでも二週間でも大丈夫というふうなこともあるし
でも快楽というものから余計それが入っちゃうとお金がいくらあっても足らないんですよ
豪華な服を買いたいとかね
ブランドのカバンが欲しいとかね
ダイヤがついてるもうジュエリーとかもうね
リングとか買いたいとかね
豪華な料理を食べる 友達とパーティーをやりながら遊びたいとか思うと
それ快楽世界 別にそんなものなくても生きていられますよ
カバンはブランド品でないと死んだ人は一人もいないでしょうに
余計なことだから 仕事暇がないんです
ずっと仕事してるんです
しかし 働き対収入の割合は業によって定めています
誰でも同じ量の働きに同じ量の収入は得られませんよ
どれぐらい働けばどれぐらい収入になるのかという割り当てがあるんですよ
それによって収入が決めるんですよ
これがわからないんですよ
業のことだから 一対一か
二対一か 一対二か分からない
少々の仕事して大量の収入を得る人々いるでしょうに
その場合 一対四とか五とか六とかなってますよ
必死で仕事をするんですけど
やっと間に合っている人々もいるでしょうに
その場合は三対一とかね
業は働きは三で 収入は一とかね
その割り当ては死ぬまで変わらないんです
割合は 人間は余計に快楽
贅沢を欲しがるから 他の生命より必死で大量の仕事をしなくてはならないんですよ
人間は他の犬 動物よりは必死で仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
これは人間 余計に快楽
いらん贅沢を求むからなんですよ
いらんのだから 自己破壊するんですよ
必要な贅沢だったら贅沢とも言えないんですよ
必要な快楽ならもう快楽と言えないんですよ
いらんもの 必要でもないものを欲しがるでしょう
だったらその分むちゃな仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
現代 我々置かれている状態はそういう状態なんです
簡単に生きていられるのに
大変ですよ 生きることは
忙しいのは自分のせいですから
欲や怒りがある限り 必需品の量が増えるので
仕事をする以外暇はありません
欲が多いんだからね その分仕事をする羽目になるのです
怒りも同じですよ 負けたくはないとかね
それは業のせいではありません
業はそんな悪いことをしないんですよ
業は多いですからね 私たちがそのそれより感情欲を作って
必要でないものも期待する
小欲知足であるならば
人生はとても楽しい 楽です
ものすごい楽なんです
人間の生まれは善業の結果です
人間に生まれたのは善業の結果ですよ
だから我々は本来ならものすごく穏やかで
ものすごく楽しく ものすごく豊かで
気楽にのんびり生きていられる生命ですよ
ほとんど神々とそれほど変わりがないんです
仏教から見れば 神々と違うところはもうもう年取る
病気になる それから料理などは作って食べなくちゃいけない
ただそれだけ 他は全部神々と同じなんですが
今はね 人間の生命は何やというと
神々に近いところか ほとんど餓鬼に近い地獄に近いところの生き方でしょう
これは業のせいじゃないんです
それは人間の余計な煩悩のせいなんです
心の汚れ 汚れというのは根拠のない感情
欲望 見栄 他人に打ち勝つ気持ちなどですね
いっぱいありますね 煩悩は
善業の働きを妨げている
そこで私たちは良い合意をして生まれてるんだけど
この働かなくなっちゃうんですよ
コンピューターでいえば
何か入れたプログラムがおかしくて引っかかっちゃう
何かウイルスが入ったりして
コンピューターウイルスとかおかしくなっている
そういうことで 私たちは本当は幸福なんですけど
それがもう機能できなくなって壊れてしまっているんです
時々仕事は嫌になって
このような気持ちにもなってしまう
例えば 何のために稼ぐのかという疑問なんですね
時々仕事もものすごい嫌になるんですよ
収入は足らないか 人間関係は悪いか
才能はないか 才能は生かせないか
財産を使う道はないか
あとはいろいろ原因があるんですよ
お金があるんだけど 使う道がない
しかし 会社の社長だからもう仕事に行かなくちゃいけない
金はいくらでもあるんだけど
社長だったらもう暇がないんですね
嫌になるんですね もうなんでこんな朝早く起きて夜遅くまであれいろいろ会議やったり
いろんなところに走ったりしてて
ということは あるいは才能が生かせない
これ嫌になるんですよ
それはいろんなことで
仕事をしてもしても収入がない場合はね
もうやりたい気持ち消えちゃいますよ
本来の人生は稼ぐだけの生き方ではないから
もう一つ原因がありますよ
本来の人間の命っていうのは
稼ぐだけで死ねという生き方じゃないんですよ
一部の時間だけ稼いだらいいんですよ
我々は幸福に生きられる運命で生まれてるんですよ
だからそんなたくさん稼がなくてもいいんです
人生の一部だけ これを忘れているんだから
だから金儲けだけをしている時
虚しさと衝突することもあります
もう仕事ばっかりやっていると
時々なんかえらい虚しさ
何やってるんですかと
一体全体私は何やと 衝突するんですよ
それは道から外れてるんだからなんです
適当な量稼いでればそうなりませんよ
正しく生きていれば 地雷を踏んでよ
小判の雨が降っても人の欲は満たせないってのはブッダの言葉なんです
ナカハパナヴァッセナ ティッティカーメス ヴィッジャティという
人間は必需品を揃う主義ではなく
これが正しい主義なんですよ
ではなく 欲を満たす主義で生きているので
欲だけではなく国もリミットがないんですよ
ちょっと文章ちょこっとややこしくなってますけど
まずお釈迦様の論理を感じ
それはすごい親切な言葉なんですよ
小判の雨が降ってもあなたの欲望を満たせませんよと
もっと欲しがるんだから欲望を捨てろって意味なんですよ
苦しいんだよと それで仕事はしなくちゃいけない
仏教から見ると 必需品
必需品そろってもらわないととんでもないことになりますよ
ご飯は必要ですし 服は必要でしょうし
家が必要でしょうし それは必要ですよ
その分だけ仕事をすればいいんです
必需品をそろえそろえますよと
ちゃんと電気代ガス代払いますよと
自分で 住民税もちゃんと住民税と
何て言いますか 国民の何とか何て言いますか
みんな払わなくちゃいけない
何て言いますかね 国民年金とかね
そういうのはちゃんと自分で払いますよとかね
それぐらいだったら何のことないんだけど
人間は欲を満たすために仕事をするんですよ
ものすごい危なくて ものすごい邪見で
邪道でキリがないんです
だからむちゃくちゃなんです
人間の人生は そんないくら仕事したっても欲は満たせませんよ
だから仕事をすればするほど苦しみ
苦しみ 苦しみばっかり
時々金儲けばっかりしていると
家族はバラバラで 子供が不良になったりして
殺人まで犯したりする
それって明らかに不幸でしょ
欲を満たせたんだからなんですよ
幸福に気楽に生きていられる運命なのに
人は地雷を踏んでるんです
欲を満たすということ
もうどうにもならない
だから今でも欲を満たす主義を必需品を揃えるという主義に入れ替えれば
もう地雷はないんです
すごく楽しんで生きていられるんです
それで結果 景気が悪い
仕事がない もう破産 倒産
収入は足らない 自然破壊
資源は足らない 競争に負ける
仕事はきつい 不正違反行為など
あらゆるもの世の中にあるでしょう
何ですかねそれが なんで人間だけ地球を破壊してるんですかね
人間の数っていうのはすごい少ないでしょうね
動物と比べてみると 動物は自然は微妙にでも破壊しない
ものすごく調和している
それにした人間は 生きることで日々自然を破壊するんです
なんででしょうかね 欲を満たすんだからなんですよ
必需品だけもらうと自然破壊にはなりません
うまくバランス調和取れるんですよ
なんで破産倒産あるんですかね
欲を満たすんだからなんです
それから仕事のストレス
能力は向上しないことも
仕事環境が悪くなるのも
やる気が失うことも 地雷を踏んでるせいなのです
みんな言ってる文句でしょうね
ストレス溜まるわ 能力はなかなか開発できない
自分の仕事環境はすごく悪いんだと
人間関係とかね 欲を満たすことの結果なんです
地雷を踏んでいる